you said there guys here who are bigger
than I am run faster jump higher not
everybody was better than me but I had
them all cranking up one of the best
decisions that you can ever make in your
life is to play to your strengths when
you know what you got going for you
be confident not cocky rise and shine
it's Xpress Oh time good morning believe
nation it's Evan my one word is believe
and I believe in you I believe you have
an amazing gift inside you that I want
to see exploded onto the world so grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
play to your strengths over to you Dave
Chappelle do you remember how they first
discovered comedy yes I do yes I do dr.
Yvonne Seon is Dave Chappelle's mother
she's a minister and a college professor
I think the moment he decided to be a
comedian was a day that he had to decide
whether or not to sign up for the second
week of basketball camp and he called
home he said mom you said there guys
here who are bigger than I am run faster
jump higher not everybody was better
than me but I had them all cranking up
so I figured maybe let me tweak my
vision
let's go get my old high school just in
encourage the kids and I told them
straight up I said if y'all want to make
it out of this ghetto you're gonna have
to stop blaming the white people for
your problems you're gonna have to focus
and you were gonna have to learn how to
rap I'll play basketball ass up you're
trapped [ __ ] you are trapped either
dude that'll sell crack rocks it's all
the way I've seen at work one of the
best decisions that you can ever make in
your life is to play to your strengths I
think the challenge is a lot of people
don't know what their ultimate strengths
are and if that's you then that becomes
your first priority figure out what you
love what you're great at and go all-in
on that too many people are living
somebody else's version of their life
you're doing the thing that your mom
wants you to do you're doing the thing
that your country wants you to do or the
school system wants you to do you're
doing the thing your uncle your friends
want you to do where most people don't
have a very clear vision of what they
want to do for themselves what they have
Michael Jordan level talent Act I
believe that everybody has Michael
Jordan level talent at something and if
you don't know what that is and that
becomes your immediate first
responsibility to figure that out
because otherwise you're living a life
with zero Direction you're doing
something because a magazine says that
this is a hot thing to do or because
some celebrity is doing something and
now you want to do it you have no
internal compass and so you're following
everybody else and that leads to a
really unhappy place at least a place of
of self-hate that leads to a place of
lack of confidence constantly and
searching for other people to give you
answers where the answer comes from here
comes from within from you figuring out
that thing that you love doing if you
don't know what it is that you want to
do then you start by exploring you say
yes you say yes you say yes you try it a
whole bunch of things until you find the
thing that makes you come alive I look
at my journey of helping entrepreneurs
and I was speaking at a couple of events
internationally after I sold my first
company and I just loved that idea of
giving back somebody asked me to speak
in an event because I had sold my
business as a young entrepreneur had
some success and so said yeah I'll do
that why not I'll say yes I didn't know
what I wanted to do next in my life I
actually had a dip I had some mild
depression because I'd sold my business
which is great you know hard to complain
about that but I didn't know
I wanted to do next I didn't have my
purpose and so I said yes the whole
bunch of things and one of them was
speaking I spoke in Mexico I spoke in
Brunei and I came back home and I said
hey why don't I do this locally like why
can't I do this for Toronto
entrepreneurs in my own City and I had
my first event that we promoted like
crazy with the YMCA and only three
people showed up to it and I thought I'd
never be able to make money from this if
three people only show up to a free
event that was promoted like crazy how
are you ever gonna make money doing this
thing as a living it didn't matter
though because I loved it and this is
what you find so often with so many the
most successful people it doesn't make
logical sense at the beginning how this
thing is gonna play out if you looked at
my early career helping entrepreneurs of
three people at a small YMCA event you
would never think that I would get here
you would never think that I'd be able
to have a big impact you would never
think I'd be able to make this into a
business and this is a story of so many
people at the beginning you look at what
they did and it was mediocre and it was
very poor results and you would never
think that they would go on to be a huge
success but they did because they loved
what they did because they had insane
passion for their craft and they got so
good at it that their talent became
undeniable and I badly want that for you
to find the thing that you have Michael
Jordan level talent act to stop doing
the boring crappy job that you have
right now to stop doing something
because somebody else wants you to do it
instead of the thing that you want to do
for yourself stop that how long you're
gonna live that life if you don't know
what it is that you want to do explore
explore explore until you find the thing
that you want to come back to and just
have the confidence the belief that if
you keep doing it you will get good at
it you will find a customer base you'll
find a way to make money and to make
this into your career now I've got some
special bonus clips for you but before
that my question of the day is I want to
know what do you have Michael Jordan
level of talent at leave it down the
comments below I'm really curious to
find out thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love
enjoy the bonus clips and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events beso
let's pray so give me go
one of my weak points in my personal
life is I don't like technical stuff so
even though I have to be on Twitter and
Instagram and Facebook I don't care for
that so guess what I find somebody who
loves to do that you know I find
somebody who has a strength where I will
have a weakness and I partner with them
all you're trying to do is get to the
goal
no one gets there by themselves
everybody needs help
now when you know what you got going for
you be confident not cocky managing your
strengths knowing what they are and
don't let nobody talk you out of it and
that gets you fight ready
you get fight ready like that you've got
to know you helps you develop your
skills all the while you're developing
your strengths is not it you've just got
to keep developing this trip don't
everybody talk to you at the same time
you must work on improving your
weaknesses so I've had to in spite of
myself get on Instagram get on Twitter
get on Facebook I got to do two videos
whether I want to or not because the
world is moving to social media if I had
as many followers as Kim Kardashian I
probably wouldn't even have to do this
TV show you need to bet on your
strengths and don't give a about where
you suck at you're gonna way too many
people in this room are gonna spend the
next 30 40 years of their lives trying
to check the boxes other things that
they're not as good at and that you're
gonna waste a lot of time and lose I
highly recommend auditing yourself or if
you have no empathy or EQ or
self-awareness then find somebody in
your family or friendship that does and
let them tell you who you are and once
you believe that either for yourself or
someone else told you go directly all
chips all into that because that is the
only possible way in my opinion watching
from the outside that is limited phrase
that is a very highly likely way of
over-indexing because the truth is if
you want to be an anomaly you've got to
act like one you know like and so that's
it that's what I got so thanks for
having me
we need to know what your unique
strengths are and be willing to delegate
so I would say that the question of
whether you should take a skill learn it
yourself delegated someone else or hire
a new team member are determined by
having a very accurate self assessment
and assessment of your team's skills not
only what you can do but what you should
be doing that's very important so if
you're a startup CEO or founder and you
have a team of say two to ten people as
soon as you have funds to hire you
should not be focused on the things that
you are bad at sounds very very
intuitive but it's not because you might
have enough time to do those things but
the question is do you have the
attention to dedicate to this thing so
they're not an interruption especially
if you are a venture back startup and
you're competing against other companies
that also have a lot of funding the game
the game and the race goes to the Swift
so you have to have you have to have a
lot of velocity the most important if
you had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you up or
that would be like a little beacon pay
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details